This video is brought to
you by Squarespace from
websites and online stores to
marketing tools and analytics.
Squarespace is the all in one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business head to squarespace.com
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch,
go to squarespace.com forward slash
biographics to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain.
Queen Victoria Earl's.
I have a Great Britain for 63 years and
she has still remembered as being one of
the most influential monarchs in history
when it comes to the life of Queen
Victoria.
Biographers are actually very lucky
because she wrote journals and letters
documenting her daily life from the
time she was a teenage girl all the way
through to our death.
Therefore,
we know exactly what she was
experiencing in her own words. However,
when she was close to death,
she also said doors,
a bare trust at edit and rewrite many
of our journals and destroy much of the
original text that might offend
members of our family. After her death,
the children took it upon themselves
to burn certain chunks of our life that
they were embarrassed of. Because
of that, we have the image of her.
That's how children wanted us to see who
was known as the widow of Windsor and
spent her entire life mourning the
death of her husbands, but our life.
It was far more interesting than
she's often given credit for
Victoria.
His grandfather was George the third.
He was the reigning King of
England's during a youth.
Pat Father was Prince Edward,
the Duke of Kensington Mother Victoria
of sacs called [inaudible] was born in
Germany before she became
the Duchess of Kent.
Prince Edward would have
become the next king.
He died when Victoria was very young,
leaving her to be the only
legitimate adds to the throne.
Victoria grew up knowing that one day she
would become the next queen of England.
By the time women were never
trusted with their own finances.
To make matters worse, the Duchess
of Kent, evenly spaced gem and,
but she was expected to
raise an English queen.
So a man named John Conroy was appointed
as the comptroller of the lives of
Victoria and her mother Conan right,
took his duty much further
than just being an accountant.
He would send opportunists to Seoul this
as a chance to have a powerful position
in the government since pushed for control
over the way Victoria was raised and
it lots of ways. He became almost
like a talent agents for a child star.
From an outsider's perspective,
it would seem the young Victoria,
she had the perfect life.
She was raised in the beautiful home of
Kensington Palace with toys clay or the
sevens and vacations broad,
but in a journals.
Victoria often wrote that she had a very
unhappy challenge it together with a
mother, Conroy created strict rules
known as the Kensington System.
The main goal of its designed was to make
Victoria Week and completely incapable
of doing anything on her own.
She was always in the company of
a chaperone wherever she went.
Instead of going to school,
she had a governess to Zaha and she
was never allowed to play with other
children.
This was an extremely lonely knife and
she desperately wants to friends Conroy
and Victoria's mother. They hopes this
if they broke the princess down enough,
they could turn it into a puppet that
was easy to control. As a teenager,
Conroy arranged for a tour on a train so
the Victoria could see every major city
in the UK.
She was forced to try and memorize every
single person's name and title at every
dinner party. Considering these
dinner parties where massive task,
it was always going to be a failure.
Conroy would reprimand her saying
that she was too stupid to be queen.
Needless to say,
the demands and the constant onslaught
of insults made a completely miserable.
In 1835 she was visiting the town of
Ram's gate and she became very ill with
typhoid fever. Conroy accused her
of being lazy and being a liar.
He said that she was faking her illness
in order to get out of the tour,
but she truly was sick and she
was lying in bed in a hotel.
John Coleman right burst into that hotel
room with a piece of paper and hands.
He said that she would be a horrible
queen and demanded the tree Sinoway have
power to him so that he could
be her personal secretary.
This would have made him king by proxy
because he would have had an absolute
power over all of her affairs.
She was just 16 years old at the time and
she spend her entire life being broken
down to feel completely worthless,
but she still had the
strength to say no to this.
When she was 18 Victoria was awoken in
the middle of the night by her mother and
she learns that her grandfather,
he was dead.
She came downstairs to find
the entrepreneurship of
Canterbury kneeling in front
of her and just like that.
She was the queen of Great Britain.
On the day of Queen Victoria's coronation,
the prime minister, Lord Melbourne,
was so moved by the beauty of the
ceremony that he had tears in his eyes.
He congratulated her and told her that
she was going to do a wonderful job.
He looks as high with fatherly pride,
which was something that she had
never experienced in her life.
Victoria knew that she could trust him.
The prime minister became a new father
figure, runs her very first friends.
They would spend a lot of time together
doing jigsaw puzzles and taking long
walks.
She often wrote that his sense of humor
was her favorite thing about him and
that he would often make her laugh.
However,
in public she was forced
to put on a serious face,
often becoming Queen Victoria moved into
Buckingham Palace and she decided to
never speak to her mother. All Lord
Conroy again that plans who controller,
it'll completely backfired.
She hated both of them and was glad to
finally have her independence. However,
that did not stop Lord Conroy from
continuing to try and slither his way back
into power.
He approached Lord Melbourne claiming
that the queen promised him a pension of
3000 pounds a year as well as a title,
some lands and a seat and caught
Melbourne gave into Conroy's demands.
After hearing about his line is
Victoria at dismissed board corn Rye,
but he continued to work for the Duchess
of Ken's while they plotted the next
move when Lord Melbourne's time is prime
minister was over and he was voted out
of office Victoria.
She was devastated.
She wrote a mounted in a journals with
so much drama or is it was almost as if
he had died. Robert Peale became
the next prime minister. Runt.
He treats head like a stupid girl,
just like John Conroy hat.
He was part of the Tory,
but as a grill party.
So he demanded the Victoria dismiss
her ladies in waiting because they were
members of the Whig party,
Victoria's bed chamber maids.
They were her dearest friends.
So she was outraged at the suggestion
that she should follow them over politics.
She flat out refused to continue
to obey peels orders after all,
she was the queen, so he didn't really
have any rights to make demands of her.
Robert Hill was so frustrated that
he could not control it. There's,
he actually resigned from
being prime minister.
This incident became known
as the bedchamber crisis.
Okay.
Even though Victoria's
mother and John Conroy,
we're no longer on
speaking terms with her.
They were still trying to give more
power to the German part of the family.
They're instructed Prince Albert's,
her first cousin.
It's a quarter with the plots to get
their family more control over the throne.
Victoria had only met Alberto ones
before and by the time they were both 20
years old, she was shocked at
how handsome had grown up to be.
She ran home so rice in her journal
about how attractive he was and how her
heart was pounding. Victoria had
no idea that her mother had plans.
This clandestine meeting
with Albert's Miss.
They truly did fall in
love with one another.
She was head over heels
in love and as the Queen,
she was the one to ask Albert
to marry her in her diary.
There are so many intimate details about
their honeymoon and it might as well be
a romance novel. Victoria at became
pregnant just a month after our wedding.
She was in constant
pain and very hormonal.
She struggled a lot with pregnancy and
she was extremely critical of herself
falling into a serious depression.
Victoria would write in a diary about
how guilty she felt every time she lost
her temper.
She would often writes that her husband
was perfect since she hated herself for
being anything but sweet and so
loving towards him at all times.
Little did the queen.
No,
this was all parts of an extension of
Conroy and the Duchess of Kent Kensington
Plan.
Allbirds German family instructed him
to keep getting her pregnant so that she
would remain a week and never have time
to truly learn how to rule on her own.
She rode the pregnancy,
made a miserable,
but they had a total of nine
children together. Unfortunately,
Victoria did not like her kids very much.
Motherhood's it was simply something she
was not ready for and she suffered from
a lot of postpartum depression
for all of those years.
She stated she had a lowness
and the tendency to cry.
It is what every lady suffers with
moral less what I during my first
confinements suffered dreadfully with.
All right,
so Victoria is life is about to get a
whole lot more tragic and I mean I don't
want to buy a graphics video
be without plenty of tragedy,
but before we get into that,
let me take a moment to tell you about
Squarespace who make these long videos
possible. Squarespace, it
empowers dreamers, makers do us.
I really liked that ad copy.
It gives them the tools to bring
their creative ideas to life.
Squarespace and get easy to,
they have an all in one platform so you
can claim a domain dollar website and
even sell on line.
There's no fussing around is getting that
domain from one website bringing into
another working out how to
sell something or whatever.
It's all neat and tidy on Squarespace
in. Thanks. I've got a personal here,
I'm working on a website
with them right now.
I have the domain bought it somewhere
else. Had to transfer it over.
It was relatively easy with Squarespace
but just by your end Janine on
Squarespace and trust me
and that would be easier.
Plus that website you make not
going to look too shabby either.
And by that I mean it's
going to look amazing.
They've got award winning templates,
which is a perfect starting point of
the and and customize it to your heart's
content plus 24 seven customer support,
chat and email.
And they've also got loads of accessible
and not confusing documentation on how
to make your website great.
Plus email marketing so you can keep in
touch with your fans or your customers.
Look Squarespace, they make it easy.
Gather that domain, get that site bills,
get a shop up and running.
If you want to do it all with Squarespace,
head to squarespace.com for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch to go
to squarespace.com forward slash
biographics and save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain I
sketch and that tragedy shall we.
In the year 1861 queen
Victoria's mother died of cancer.
Despite all the drama that had
gone on between the two of them,
she regretted not spending
more time with a mother.
She realized that John Conroy was the
true villain here and she regretted not
taking action to repair
their relationships sooner.
That same year though,
her husband Albert,
he also died.
She was 42 years old and suddenly
the closest people in their life,
they were gone after his death.
She continued to sleep next to a picture
of him and have the sevens lay out his
clothes on the bed every
morning even though he wouldn't
be there to get dressed.
Whenever someone asked her to make a
decision, she would accidentally say,
I'll have to ask Albert's as her.
She had forgotten or was in
denial about his death. Victoria,
she already struggles with mental illness,
but these deaths,
they made it follow us.
They bill whispered that she may have
inherited the Hanoverian madness off to
rule. There was so much inbreeding going
on and that part of a family that it
shouldn't be surprising those all of
them were known for being a bit nuts.
She dressed in black at all times
and acted completely melodramatic.
She write letters on paper with a
black border to signify that she was in
mourning instead of staying
in Buckingham Palace.
She went on long holidays
and Germany in a diary.
She right that she wished she could
have a normal life and she could live in
Germany with albus without having to be
queen at this points, everyone begins.
Cool, Huh? The widow of Windsor,
for the rest of our life,
Victoria wore black every single day.
She went on one of the longest
periods of mourning in history.
People thought that this
was tragically romantic,
so they become fascinated with death.
Suddenly it was fashionable to
enjoy spooky and creepy things,
and this inspired a great deal of
amazing culture during the Victorian era.
Now most people think that this is a
story ends and she remains a very sad and
serious woman for the rest of the days,
but the reality is is that she was able
to heal and she learned to love her life.
Once again
after returning to the United Kingdom
and Victoria and met a Scottish man named
John Brown when she was 45 old brown had
been Prince Albert's assistant whenever
he visited Scotland,
so he was there to pay his respects.
Instead of seeing her just as the queen,
he could see that Victoria was an
incredibly lonely woman and all she really
needed in our life.
It was a friends.
The two of them would get into long
conversations where she pulled out all of
the feelings that she had kept secrets
or just only recent in her diaries for a
very long time.
Brown had a lot of sympathy for her.
Runs became devoted to serving hat.
He swore that he would never leave
aside and take care of her every need.
The greatest gift John Brown gave a was
his personality. He was loud, he was rude.
It was almost always drunk.
He would drink whiskey,
something some into Victoria's
drink saying, don't stay thirsty.
No one had made Victoria at loft so much
and years and she absolutely loved it.
The ticket became best friends
and even possibly lovers.
If Brown disagreed with something he did,
he would yell, woman, what are you doing?
I'll look as shocked at
his level of disrespect,
but she actually enjoyed it very much.
No one had ever dent to talk to her like
that. So Teresa, like a normal person.
Her entire life, everyone had treated
her like she was weak and stupid,
but John Brown,
he knew how smart and strong she truly
was saying he held to a higher standard.
That friendship,
it lifted our spirits house.
I've had depression and she
was the happiest. She had
been in a very long time.
All their life.
Victoria was rising in our journals every
single day and she was an avid reader.
She made a decision to do something that
no other Monique has ever done before.
Become an author.
Queen Victoria published a book called
leaves from the Journal of our lives in
the highlands,
which was full of access from our own
personal journal about a friendship with
John Brown and how he changed my life.
It became a best seller and sold
over a hundred thousand copies.
She even gave a dedication to
drawn Brown's muscular legs,
which peaked out of his kilt that kids,
they were embarrassed,
but then again any kid would
feel embarrassed of them.
Other wrote about those things and
then publish them off to a death.
Victoria Victoria's daughter Beatrice
deleted all mention of John Brown when she
was rewriting Victoria's journals because
that relationship was considered to be
Yay Trudy humiliating
stain on the royal family,
but of course she couldn't
alter raise him from history.
Queen Victoria had commissioned statues
to be made and John Brown's on errands,
plenty of people who witnessed
them together when he was alive.
Victoria and John held hands together and
hugged one another in public and so of
course there was also the book she
published about that friendship.
There is also a remit.
They were secretly lovers Victoria and
they'd show the snaps in conjoining
bedrooms and dead children called
him mamma's love up on his deathbed.
The Queen's personal chaplain referenced
Norman Cloud confessed that he married
Queen Victoria and John Brown
in secret ceremony is they said,
and we would learn that he gave
her his mother's engagement ring.
Tragically though she outlived Brown too,
even though he was several
years younger than hot.
He died at age 56 so she lost yet another
man in her life that she truly loved.
In 1997 a movie called Mrs. Brown was
made to dramatize that love story.
Despite the evidence there
are still historians.
He refused to believe that Queen Victoria
would marry a common name like John
Brown and if she had the things,
you would have been brave enough to let
the world know instead of keeping it a
secret.
Unfortunately,
we never know all the details
because there've been lost forever.
As we mentioned before,
Queen Victoria was incapable of running
a government's on our own and she was
known for being a bit off her rocker.
The decisions she made were usually
based on her personal preferences rather
than politics.
Prime Minister Gladstone,
he was very serious and you didn't
have any sense of humor. It's whole.
So of course Victoria,
how you just him.
They would write nasty letters back and
forth to one another even though they
both would have done Buckingham Palace
and could have easily spoken to one
another face to face the
next prime minister Disraeli.
It has a much better sense of
humor and treated her with respect.
He would compliment how orange
treat her like the role she wants.
Disraeli lovingly called her the fairy
queen and gave her the title empress of
India. Queen Victoria had never
been to India in her entire life,
but it's often being given the title.
She sat down and learn as much about
the country as she possibly could.
She hired a tutor named Abdul Kareem so
that she could learn to speak the Indian
language Hindustani in how notebooks.
She took notes every time she asked
him how to save for the Taisha,
so dirty things.
Crim became a new favorite seven since
he was given the title of the Munchy or
the teacher. Victoria allows
him to go with her everywhere,
even when she was on holiday
compared to the loud John Brown.
The people in Queen Victoria is
course well, actually relieves the,
her new favorite servant was at least
a soft spoken and a real gentleman.
They saw this as a huge improvements.
However,
the Curran soon began to get showered
with gifts and gained a lot more
privileges.
Plenty of people were concerned
the Victoria was going
to be taken advantage off
and that she was making poor decisions,
often wielding a good two's.
I didn't exactly qualify Kareem to become
someone who held a position of power,
but the moments, anyone questions,
anything to do with career,
she would accuse them of being racist.
Abdul Karim was always getting sick
and it turns out that he had gotten
gonorrhea,
but of course if the Raul physician got
frustrated at Victoria would pull the
race card.
Once again.
He came with a on vacation and the Riviera
runs the newspapers described in this
a seventh she writes me a letter to the
newspaper and demanded that they retract.
Then I'll story and submit a correction.
Abdul Karim was an educated
gentleman and to and secretary.
While she was incredibly eccentric.
There is no doubt this once anyone
became Queen Victoria's friends,
she was fiercely loyal and it's
made sure they lived that best life.
Hm.
At 81 years old,
Queen Victoria out plans for her death
and when she had a hemorrhagic stroke,
they knew how to per Patho have funeral.
Throughout that life,
Queen Victoria had been
given precious jewels,
but they meant nothing to
her in those final days.
She told her doctors that what she wanted
was a number of sentimental items with
her in a coffin.
First was Albert's dressing gown,
which she had in their bedroom
all of those years. Next, well,
the photos of the children as well as
the locks of their hair that she had
collected from their first hack outs.
She requested to have a framed
photograph of John Brown in our hands.
Lang over our heart on her finger.
She wore an engagement ring that belongs
to John Brown's mother, Queen Victoria.
His took place on February.
The second is 1901 despite it
being in the middle of winter,
thousands of people showed up to mourn
and it became one of the largest funerals
in history.
She never let the country three war or
haven't made any substantial improvements
in politics, but people,
they loved her all the same.
So many prime ministers came and
went during Victoria's reign.
There have been all but forgotten.
You could say that they were some
of the first true influences.
Everything they did caused a ripple
effect for the rest of society and Queen
Victoria was no exception.
In fact at life was so colorful this
and we think of the Victorian era.
We truly do gas, a very vivid image
of that time period in our minds,
the clothes,
the style and the attitude of the
people that would just like the queen,
serious on the outside and wild
on the inside. It's delicious.
Lee Romantic and yet very
dark at the same time.
That time period is still popular to this.
Dan Queen Victoria is going to be
remembered as one of the most impactful
figures in history. So I really hope you
found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below
and do not forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos just like
this several times a week. Also,
fantastic sponsors. Squarespace shank
then aren't below, and as always,
thank you for watching.